so all of a sudden AI is everywhere
people who weren't quite sure what it
was or playing with it on their phones
is that good or bad yeah so I've been
um thinking about AI for a long time
since I was in college really
um it was one of the things that the
sort of four or five things I thought
would really uh affect the future
dramatically it is fundamentally
profound in that the
the smartest creatures as far as we know
on this Earth are humans
um is our defining characteristic yes we
obviously uh weaker than say chimpanzees
are less agile
um but real smarter
so
now what happens when something
vastly smarter than the smartest person
comes along in Silicon foam it's very
difficult to predict what will happen in
that circumstance it's called The
Singularity it's you know it's a
singularity like a black hole because
you don't know what happens after that
it's hard to predict
so I think we should be cautious with AI
and we should
I think there should be some
government oversight because it affects
the it's a danger to the public and so
when you when you have things that are
endangered to the public uh
you know like let's say
um
so Food Food and Drugs That's why we
have the Food and Drug Administration
right and the Federal Aviation
Administration uh the FCC
uh we have we have these agencies to
oversee things that uh affect the public
where they could be public harm
and you don't want companies cutting
Corners uh on safety
um
and then having people suffer as a
result so that's why I've actually for a
long time been a strong advocate of uh
AI regulation
um something I think regulation is
uh you know it's not fun to be regulated
it's a sort of somewhat of a
I saw an audience to be regulated I have
a lot of experience with regular
regulated Industries because obviously
Automotive is highly regulated you could
fill this room with all the regulations
that are required for a production car
just in the United States and then
there's a whole different set of
regulations in Europe and China and the
rest of the world so
very familiar with being overseen by a
lot of regulators
and the same thing is true with rockets
you can't just willy-nilly you know
shoot Rock itself or not big ones anyway
because the FAA is overseas that
um and then even to get a launch license
you there are
probably half a dozen or more federal
agencies that need to approve it uh plus
state agencies so it's I'm I've been
through so many regulatory
uh situations it's insane and and but
you know sometimes I I people think I'm
some sort of like
regulatory Maverick that sort of defies
Regulators on a regular basis but this
is actually not the case uh so uh in you
know once in a blue moon rarely I will
disagree with Regulators but the vast
majority of the time uh my companies
agree with the regulations and comply
us anyway so I think I think we should
take this seriously and and we should
have
um a regulatory agency I think it needs
to start with
um a group that initially seeks uh
insight into AI uh then solicits opinion
from industry and then has proposed
rulemaking and then those rules
you know uh we'll probably hopefully
gradually be accepted by
the major players in in Ai and um
and I think we'll have a better chance
of
um Advanced AI being beneficial to
humanity in that circumstance but all
regulations start with a perceived
danger and planes fall out of the sky or
food causes botulism yes I don't think
the average person playing with AI on
his iPhone perceives any danger can you
just roughly explain what you think the
dangers might be
yeah so the the the the danger really AI
is
um
perhaps uh
more dangerous than say mismanaged uh
aircraft design or production
maintenance or or bad car production in
the sense that it is
it has the potential however small one
make regard that probability but it is
non-trivial and has the potential of
civilizational Destruction
there's movies like Terminator but it
wouldn't quite happen like Terminator
um because the the intelligence would be
in the data centers right the robot's
just the end effector
but I think perhaps what you may be
alluding to here is that
um
regulations are really only pointed to
effect after something terrible has
happened that's correct if that's the
case for AI and we're only putting
regulations after something terrible has
happened it may be too late to actually
put the regulations in place the AI may
be in control at that point
you think
that's real it is it is conceivable that
AI could take control and reach a point
where you couldn't turn it off and it
would be making
the decisions for people yeah absolutely
absolutely no it's that's that's
definitely the way things are headed
uh for sure uh
I mean um
things like like say uh chat EVT which
is based on jpd4 from openai which is
the company that I
played a a critical role in in creating
unfortunately back when it was a
non-profit
yes
um
I mean the the reason uh openai exists
at all is that
um
Larry Page and I used to be close
friends and I would stay at his house in
Palo Alto and I would talk to him later
tonight about uh AI safety and at least
my perception was that Larry was not
taking uh AI safety uh seriously enough
um and um what did he say about it he
really seemed to be
um
sort of digital super intelligence
basically digital God if you will uh as
soon as possible um he wanted that
yes he's made many public statements
over the years uh that the whole goal of
Google is uh what's called AGI
artificial general intelligence or
artificial super intelligence you know
and I agree with him that the there's
great potential for good
um but there's also potential for bad
and so if if you've got some
um radical new technology you want to
try to take a set of actions that
maximize probably it will do good a
minimize probably will do bad things yes
it can't just be Health leather let's
just go you know barreling forward and
you know hope for the best and then at
one point uh I said well what about you
know we're going to make sure humanity
is okay here
um
and and and
uh and then he called me a speciesist
[Laughter]
that term yes
and there were Witnesses the other I
wasn't the only one there when you
called me a speciesist and so I was like
okay that's it uh I've yes I'm a
speciesist okay you got me
what are you
yeah I'm fully auspicious um
busted um so
um that was the last rule at the time uh
Google uh had a quite Deep Mind and so
Google deepmind together had about three
quarters of all the AI talents in the
world they obviously had a trans amount
of money and more computers than anyone
else so I'm like okay we're about
unipolar world here where there's just
one one company that it has
close to Monopoly on AI talent and uh
and computers like so scaled Computing
and a person who's in in charge doesn't
seem to care about safety this is not
good so
what's the the furthest thing from
Google would be like a non-profit that
is fully open because Google was closed
for profit so that's why the open and
open AI refers to open source uh you
know transparency so people know what's
going on yes and that it we don't want
to have like a I mean well I'm normally
in favor of for-profit we don't want
this to be sort of a profit maximizing a
demon from hell that's right that just
never stops right so that's how I open
air was so you want specious incentives
here incentives that yes I think we went
to pro-human yeah this makes the future
good for the humans yes yes because
we're humans so can you just put it I
keep pressing it but just just for
people who haven't thought this through
and aren't familiar with it
and the cool parts of of artificial
intelligence are so obvious
you know write your college paper for
you write a limerick about yourself like
there's a lot there that's fun
and useful
can you be more precise about what's
potentially dangerous and scary like
what could it do what specifically are
you worried about
okay going with old sayings the pen is
mightier than the sword
um so if you have a super intelligent AI
that is capable of writing uh incredibly
well and in a way that is very
influential
um you know convincing
and then and as and is constantly
figuring out what is more what is more
and what is more convincing to people
over time and then enter social media
for example Twitter uh but also Facebook
and others you know um
and and potentially manipulates public
opinion in a way that is very bad
um
how would we even know
how do we even know
so to sum up in the words of Elon Musk
for all human history human beings have
been the smartest beings on the planet
now human beings have created something
that is far smarter than they are and
the consequences of that are impossible
to predict and the people who created it
don't care in fact as he put it Google
founder Larry Page a former friend of
his is looking to build a quote digital
God and believes that anybody who's
worried about that is a speciesist in
other words is looking out for human
beings first Elon Musk responded as a
human being it's okay to look out for
human beings first
and then at the end he said the real
problem with AI is not simply that it
will jump the boundaries and become
autonomous and you can't turn it off in
the short term the problem with AI is
that it might control your brain through
words
and this is the application that we need
to worry about now particularly going
into the next presidential election the
Democratic party as usual was ahead of
the curve on this they've been thinking
about how to harness AI for political
power more on that next
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight